Medical education has over the years been famous for producing clinicians who are at the top
of the profession. When I left Grady
Hospital as a resident, I went over to
Vietnam and I walked into emergency room at a M.A.S.H. unit in Vietnam and  a very harried nurse
came to me and said "Where you from?"
and I said "My training was at Emory,"
and she said, "Thank God! We need people
from Emory, they're the only people
the only people who know how to do things!"
I like to tell applicants to our house staff
training program that we had
graduates who had gone to Antarctica,
where they were the physicians for the
small band of scientists in the research
station in Antarctica. We also have had a
graduate who was one of the physicians
to this Senate. And then we had Sonny
Carter, a remarkable graduate of
Emory Medical School who came to our house
staff program and who became an
astronaut and went one of the Challengers
around the world. And so as I like to
tell the applicants, the people who
finished the program here at Emory
are sublime physicians. They're totally
confident they can handle any problem that
comes up and they stretch from the South
Pole to the Senate to going around the Earth,
and so that's the kind of people
that Emory has turned out and is famous for.